[Musik]
sie haben wahrscheinlich schon vom block
10 gehört der rummel um den
block chain ist das rückgrat der krypto
währungen es hat viele aspekte unseres
lebens verändert
dies ist wahrscheinlich der ort von dem
man denkt er könnte dadurch verändert
werden
was wäre wenn ich ihnen sagen würde dass
er noch mehr kann
die blockzeiten revolution braut sich
zusammen nicht dort wo sie denken
in diesem zweiteiligen spezial treffe
ich die züchter lassen sie mich ihnen
unseren kühlraum zeigen hier züchten wir
unsere sehr guten die
lebensmittelhändler ich möchte ihnen
noch etwas interessantes zeigen
und die startups also was man in der
physischen welt braucht ist eigentlich
das internet der dinge die welt der
lebensmittel mit blogs chain verändern
stellen sie sich vor sie wissen genau
wie viele schritte dieses foul an ton im
laufe seines lebens getan hat
kann die technologie hinter der krypto
wir uns wirklich helfen unsere
lebensmittel zu kennen
ich bekomme eine kostprobe von block
chain und warum das wichtig ist
[Musik]
die welt wird immer verrückter
und komplizierter
ich werde ihnen helfen den sinn zu
verstehen
ich bringe ihnen besseren zugang
spannende geschichten und tiefere
einblicke ich werde ihnen sagen warum es
wichtig ist
also was ist zu einfach es ist ein
riesiges buch das den austausch von
gütern die geld oder waren zwischen zwei
oder mehreren parteien aufzeichnet
stellen sie sich vor all diese daten
sind digital
und werden nicht nur auf einem sondern
auf vielen computern gespeichert
wie der name schon sagt werden
informationen über transaktionen der
virtuellen behältern in den sogenannten
blöcken gespeichert
diese blöcke sind digital
aneinandergekettet
diese verschlüsselten daten werden dann
allen computern im block chain netzwerke
zur verfügung gestellt
würden sie fast unmöglich ist
aufgezeichnete daten zu ändern
[Musik]
dieser durchbruch
werden meinung die welt verändern
wie genau das war ich von dr julien
horst autor von crypto währung einfach
erklärt also warum tun wir das damit die
leute nicht an dingen arbeiten die keine
geschäftlichen gründe haben julian ist
auch mitbegründer von the next einem
startup mit sitz in singapur so es ist
erst drei jahre alt letztes jahr war
tags unter den best finanzierten startup
der welt hier ist ein teil unseres teams
unser team ist unser kapital
investoren haben rund 80 millionen us
dollar in das erste museumsangebot von
terrex gesteckt und damit das
versprechen eingelöst crypto währung
investierbar zu machen und nx haben wir
vor etwa drei jahren angefangen und wir
fuhren von dieser sache namens crypto
währung bitcoin und so weiter und wir
dachten wie können wir all diese
virtuellen währung im echten leben
nutzen also haben wir mit einer
bankkarte angefangen die die leute mit
diesen crypto währungen verbinden können
dann können sie zu starbucks gehen und
ihre bitcoins tatsächlich für einen
kaffee ausgeben welche anderen
anwendungen gibt es was ein blog chain
macht ist anstatt informationen auf
einem firmenserver zu speichern kann ich
sie bei mir selbst speichern und ich
kann beweisen dass sich diese
informationen nicht manipuliert habe das
ist etwas was blog chains durch
kryptographie ermöglichen wie
unterscheidet sich das von anderen
datenbanken
das ist die zensur resistenz niemand
kann zensieren wie ein neuer blog
aussieht einer dieser informations
blöcke die integriert werden und niemand
kann die vergangenheit zensieren ich
kann also nicht einfach irgendetwas
entfernen oder hinzufügen ich kann
nichts blockieren diese resistenz ist
sehr mächtig weil sie verhindert dass
etwas manipuliert wird
die zweite sache ist transparenz jeder
kann die blöcke von heute bis ganz am
anfang sehen ich sehe wie der datenfluss
waren viele daten sind anonymisiert ich
kann also nicht sehen wer was gemacht
hat das ist in ordnung aber die
transparenz in diesem system ist extrem
hoch ich kann also buchstäblich sehen
wurde geld geschaffen wurde geld
vernichtet wie viel wurde tatsächlich
bewegt ich kann die teilnehmer nicht
sehen eine interessante anwendung ist
das finanzwesen denn ich kann speichern
wie viel geld ich besitze und jeder weiß
dass ich den betrag nicht verändert also
gestern hatte ich zehn dollar heute habe
ich plötzlich 10.000 dollar das könnte
ich mit blogs nicht machen es ist die
technologie also schon sehr
fortgeschritten aber noch nicht weit
verbreitet
im moment probieren wir nur herum wir
testen und sehen was möglich ist wir
sind noch in den 90er jahren des
internets also wirklich vor 20 jahren
es ist ein versuch ob das funktioniert
ob ein nutzer das tun würde es ist noch
in einem sehr frühen stadium
ich glaube es ist wirklich großartig für
unternehmen und regierungen
niemand weiß genau was in der zukunft
die entscheidenden anwendungen sein
werden
aber wir testen und wir befinden uns in
einem wirklich sehr frühen stadium
wenn ein land nicht in block 1
investiert wird es am ende den kürzeren
ziehen ich glaube eine regierung die
nicht im block chain investiert wird
verlieren das ist als würde man nicht
ins internet investieren dann hätte man
auf die letzten 20 jahre verpasst mit
block zählen gibt es viele wirklich
großartige anwendungen ich bin überzeugt
in den nächsten 20 jahren werden wir es
in allen lebensbereichen haben
er stellt sich heraus dass block chain
vielleicht schon früher auftaucht als
wir denken bei einem unserer liebsten
vergnügen dem essen
[Musik]
ich bin hier bei theresa einer
veranstaltung zum thema lebensmittel und
gastgewerbe sie hat nicht nur meine
geschmacksnerven gekitzelt sondern mir
auch futter zum nachdenken gegeben der
herkunft von lebensmitteln wie sollen
wir wissen woher unsere lebensmittel
kommen und wie können wir sicherstellen
dass diese information nicht gefälscht
werden
[Musik]
die block chain technologie ist eine
tolle anwendung dafür das was wir auf
einem etikett sehen auch wirklich das
ist was wir essen oder trinken
wir glauben dass einer der besten
anwendungsbereiche für die blogs
technologie die lieferkette ist
nach dem vortrag habe ich mich mit dem
referenten max kant elia unterhalten
max ist mitbegründer von einem kind ab
die private blogs chains für
internationale unternehmen auf
als jemand der guten wein und gutes
essen liebt ist er begeistert von der
potentiellen anwendung der block 10 auf
lebensmitteln
die blogs ein technologie wird also
immer mit crypto währung in verbindung
gebracht ja warum dann
lebensmittelindustrie
glock chain ist eine wunderbare lösung
um vertrauen und transparenz in der
gesamten lieferkette zu schaffen
vom schweinemäster bis zu unserem tisch
blog chain ermöglicht es uns jede
transaktion transparent und für jeden
verfügbar zu machen
so kann das was zb auf dem etikett steht
in die kette eingegeben werden und jeder
teilnehmer in dieser kette kann es sehen
wenn die technologie
[Musik]
1 kommentar was geschlachtet wurde
sogar noch mehr als das es sagt ihnen
wie es vom bauernhof zum vertrieb kam
vom vertrieb zum spediteur und
es wird ihnen sogar sagen mit welchem
schiffes nach singapur heißt bevor es
ins restaurant kam indem sie es
vielleicht essen
und sie können die informationen nicht
manipulieren
die block chain technologie klingt wie
das wonach die singapurische café
unternehmerin pamela chen gesucht hat
sie betreibt die kaffee akademie und
rösterei better barista
die benachteiligte frauen ausbilden
einstellen dass sie ihre kaffeebohnen
aus einer nachhaltigen quelle kommen ist
er sozial unternehmen sehr wichtig
darf ich fragen woher die bohnen stammen
wir wurden die wir heute verwenden sind
single origin kaffee aus myanmar
ist es wirklich so wichtig für ihre
kunden zu wissen woher
nun ich glaube die verbraucher machen
sich zunehmend gedanken über die
herkunft der lebensmittel für die
zutaten darüber wo unsere lebensmittel
herkommen ob sie ethisch und nachhaltig
erzeugt wurden
woher wissen sie das ihrem wohn ethisch
hergestellt
bei diesem café aus myanmar haben wir
die farmen besucht und mit den bauern
gesprochen zusammen mit unserem partner
der den kaffee dort verarbeiten
versuchen wir uns davon zu überzeugen
dass die bedingungen für die bauern gut
sind und stellen sicher dass das geld
auch bei ihnen ankommt das kostet
natürlich eine menge geld
es ist etwas das sich viele leute nicht
leisten können ich glaube mit einer
technologie wie der blog stellen bei der
man die daten nicht verändern kann haben
wir mehr möglichkeiten transparent und
authentisch mit diesen informationen
umzugehen
mit block german kunden
um zu beweisen dass sie in farmen fair
bezahlt hat könnten sie zum beispiel
einen kurzen dem etikett scan um zu
sehen ob mir ein fairtrade sieht gut aus
erstellt wurde
damit hat sie einen vorteil
deshalb trifft sie sich heute mit
einem block chain technologien drücker
wie chain mit sitz in shanghai hat sich
einen namen gemacht der aus block chains
für luxusmarken
[Musik]
im moment versuchen wir es für alle
zugänglicher zu machen also jeder ein
smartphone hat dann ist es einfach die
herkunft eines produkts zu überprüfen ja
man einen qr code auf der verpackung hat
braucht man nur ein smartphone um ihn zu
scannen dann wird er überprüft man kann
ein foto das produkt sehen so kann man
sich vergewissern dass er sich um das
richtige produkt handelt
und der aufregendste teil ist hier hier
kann man die zeit und das datum sehen
sobald etwas neues passiert und wer
daran beteiligt war das macht die
lieferkette also sehr sichtbar und man
kann nichts verändern ich kann also
nicht einfach reingehen und man kann
diese daten nicht manipulieren als
verbraucher kann ich darauf vertrauen
dass das was hier steht auch stimmt das
ist wirklich aus myanmar kommt das ist
der tag an dem es ihr lager verlassen
hat und der tag an dem es gerüstet wurde
die block 10 kann dazu beitragen dass
man nicht lügt und dass das was man in
seinem marketing an gibt auch wirklich
war die blog kann einem helfen die von
ihnen müsste ich wissen wie ihre
prozesse aussehen welche technologie ist
oder ob zum beispiel alles sehr manuelle
ja ziemlich im grunde genommen ist es so
wir arbeiten mit ineos café in myanmar
zusammen sie haben ein
verarbeitungszentrum im schönbuch land
und arbeiten mit ein paar hundert
kleinen bauern zusammen
während der erntezeit sammeln sie die
bohnen und bringen sie zur verarbeitungs
farm und dort macht genies alles fertig
dann geht es aufs schiff das schiff
kommt noch singapur wir holen es ab es
kommt in unser lager und
wenn wir dann so weit sind kommt es in
unsere lästerei da müssten wir den
kaffee und verpacken ihn in diese beutel
für den verbraucher
und dann geht s online an alle unsere
einzelhandelsstandorte
das ist also sozusagen die kette dass
man also in der physischen welt braucht
ist ein das internet der dinge zum
beispiel einen qr-code um eine kurze
kette zu veranschaulichen könnte meinen
kollegen vielleicht zu ihrem
einzelhandelsgeschäft gehen lassen und
dann bringen wir ihnen hier her und
lassen ihn wieder ein scan um zu zeigen
dass der standort an zwei verschiedenen
orten erkannt
also machen wir ihnen auf die verpackung
motto ja wir machen einen qr-code auf
die packung bringen sie in den laden und
lassen sie es kennen so dass die zeit
und der ort in der block chain angezeigt
werden
[Musik]
wie sie also sehen können ist der kaffee
am plaza singapurer angekommen er wurde
zum grün geöffnet hier ist eine zeit
dazu und auch ein ort singapur central
können wir genauer werden weil
eigentlich ist plaza singapur ja eine
bestimmte orte also zu demo zwecken
zeigen wir singapur ost oder singapur
zentrum er war natürlich wenn wir
zusammenarbeiten können wir das für sie
machen mit genaueren koordinaten wo der
scan gemacht wurde das wäre viel
nützlicher
blog chain noch mehr potenzial als nur
die rückverfolgbarkeit traceability
wenn eine kette vom bauernhof dies mit
tisch geschaffen wurde kann theoretisch
auch ein mechanismus für die bezahlung
eine tasse kaffee dazu wäre geschaffen
werden und aufgrund der transparenz die
eine blockt anbietet kann ich als
verbraucher tatsächlich verfolgen mein
geld
wenn ich nicht nur den barista trinken
die züchter direkt unterstützen will
kann ich das tun
[Musik]
die verwendung von block chain für die
rückverfolgung von lebensmitteln lässt
den sänger bono relativ neu
aber ein land
da will ich
[Musik]
laut der us amerikanischen handelskammer
in china 2016 für 86 der weltweit
gefälschten waren verantwortlich
das sind rund 400 milliarden us dollar
kein wunder dass man in china
fälschungen original nicht unterscheiden
kann aber hier geht das problem über
markenartikel hinaus
und betrifft auch die lebensmittel die
hessen
dort war
das größere problem bei gefälschten
lebensmitteln ist natürlich die
lebensmittelsicherheit
von melamin im milchpulver bis hin zum
ausgeben von rotem fleisch als
hammelfleisch die letzten zehn jahren
hat china eine reihe von
lebensmittelskandalen erlebt
[Musik]
seit dem milchpulverskandal 2008 ist
china immer noch ein heißes pflaster für
kontaminierte und gefälschte
lebensmittel
[Musik]
eine studie des pew research center aus
dem jahr 2017 ergab dass vier von zehn
chinesen ihr lebensmittelsicherheit als
sehr großes problem sehen
hier besteht also ein riesiger bedarf an
informationen über die herkunft von
lebensmitteln
denn es geht um leben oder tod
darauf reagieren jetzt einige
lebensmittel riesen
einer von ihnen ist die dot com
der einzelhändler will mit blockieren so
viele waren wie möglich bis zum
bauernhof erfolgen
und ich kann all diese informationen
bequem von meinem hotelzimmer aus
abrufen
eine einfache suche auf den beliebten
chinesischen einzelhandels plattform
zeigt mir die vielfalt der produkte
reicht von verpackten lebensmitteln mit
pulver
[Musik]
bis hin zu tierprodukten wie sehr gut
der größte rivale von alibaba es ist das
zweitgrößte e-commerce-unternehmen china
2012 begann es mit einem online einkauf
von lebensmitteln
sechs jahre später eröffnete es sein
erster stationären laden hier bei satten
träsch im norden pekings
der flagship supermarkt von jenny ist
4000 quadratmeter groß viele seiner
produkte werden über die block chain
verfolgt
sehen sie hier ist ein qr code auf der
packung
ich kann die seven fresh up öffnen und
mit der scan funktion den qr code auf
der packung scannen
zeigt mir woher es kommt eine
produktionsfirma hat die farm
informationen
das macht die lieferkette von dem gemüse
sichtbarer
[Musik]
ich möchte ihnen noch etwas
interessantes zeigen
schauen sie hier ist ein qr code auf dem
fisch
wenn ich ihn kenne komme ich auf die
seite mit den ganzen infos
sie wissen genau woher der fisch kommt
und zu welchem datum wann er gefischt
und wann er getestet wurde
der verband der lebensmittel hersteller
schätzt dass ein einziger vorfall von
lebensmittel betrug das unternehmen zwei
bis 15 prozent seines jährlichen
umsatzes kosten kann
für ein riesiges unternehmen wie adidas
im letzten jahr insgesamt 55 7
milliarden us dollar umsatz gemacht hat
könnte das ein verlust von über 1,1
milliarden dollar bedeuten
der kampf gegen lebensmittel betrug ist
also ernst
sie öffnen ihre blog chain sogar für
ihre lieferanten und andere unternehmen
damit auch sie ein sicheres und
transparenteres lieferkettenmanagement
entwickeln kann
management
der ehemalige informatik professor
doktor weit entwickelt diese technologie
als einer der meist zitierten autoren
auf diesem feld verfügt über mehr als 25
jahre akademische erfahrung
[Applaus]
wenn wir lieferkette sagen wissen wir
was das ist aber viele leute tun sich
schwerer als typische kunden tun sich
schwer eine lieferkette wirklich zu
begreifen das ist ein sehr trockenes
konzept
man kann es nicht festhalten aber
durch diesen rückverfolgung dienst
können die leute jetzt wirklich die
vorteile der block chain nutzen und die
vielen informationen erhalten die
während des gesamten prozesses gesammelt
werden
war das nicht möglich
ein vorteil der block chain ist dass man
informationen von mehreren parteien
erhalten kann und
diese parteien kennen sich vielleicht
gar nicht treffen sich nicht und
vertrauen sich vielleicht nicht einmal
und die blogs macht es möglich eine
solche zusammenarbeit auf effektive und
effiziente weise zu erleichtern
stellen sie sich vor sie wüssten genau
wann diese pilze geerntet wurden
oder ob für dieses gemüse pestizide
verwendet worden
wie viele schritte die freiland tun im
laufe seines lebens zurückgelegt hat
[Musik]
in china ist das bereits realität
heute verfolgt die 14.000 produkte von
500 marken in der glocke
[Musik]
und eines der ersten nutztiere das in
der box enthalten ist
[Musik]
nächste woche in teil 2 unseres blogs
chain spezials besuchen wir eine sogen
farming in china keine um zu sehen wie
die block chain zur sicherung der
nahrungskette eingesetzt wird ich
versuche die teuren seegurken von den
billigen zu unterscheiden
und spüre die technologie auf die eine
wiederholung des fatalen melamin mich
skandals von 2008 verhindern könnte